and if you had to sum up your drag race
experience in a couple of words what
would that be life-changing Kahana
munchies you are a young queen with a
big future now go out there and work
[ __ ] sashay away
thank you guys for everything Grace has
been the biggest thing that I think I've
ever done in my life that has made such
an impact in my mental state my physical
like well-being it's changed me
completely and I'm forever thankful for
the experience and where it's taking me
yeah and where it's going to tell where
it's going to take me because this is
just the start
it's just started and it's already been
amazing
like I never would have thought I would
be doing the things I'm doing it's so
cool to be a part of this I feel like my
drag has elevated after doing the show
like it makes you really put things in
perspective and just the growth that the
show takes you through it's so
transforming why did you learn about
yourself from doing this whole thing I
feel like doing the show I had to really
taken on constructive criticism and
really like understand that it's okay to
have different point of views and to
always just like I don't know just stay
on top of my game just to always like
put me first what do you hope the
viewers think about you um that they
just see a true performer that they see
of entertainer who gives it her all
every single time she hits the stage and
that I just build with left who from
this group is a friend for life evey for
sure silky like that's my ride-or-die
absolutely I can call her any time of
the day
and now I'm gonna get great advice now
I'm gonna get support and love for her
so yeah there's a lot of good girls on
the cast I've built a family with these
girls you know I would say before drag
race always being like in Vegas it's
really hard to like
I don't know bond with Queens because
we're all like we're in the gig we're
out the gig so this was the first time
that I actually got to really make bonds
with girls and actually like form a
sisterhood like we call we check up on
each other we're like supportive so for
me like that was the biggest thing that
I said from the show was actually having
a family that I can you know depend on
[Applause]